Kristen Brandis is conducting his daily
research each morning he trolls the net
looking for weird and wacky things or
memes he posts the best ones onto his ad
sponsored site lucky zoo rush time which
is called up as many as 60,000 times a
day my job is to keep German workers
from doing their jobs I post stuff
that's funny bizarre interesting or
creative it's usually viewed by people
looking for a distraction at work memes
are like a joke with a thousand
punchlines
all told by different internet users
they find online gags on platforms like
you're the man now dog or reddit then
they change and spread them
British evolutionary biologist Richard
Dawkins coined the term mean back in
1976 he used it in his book The Selfish
Gene to explain how ideas and cultural
phenomenon spread Kristin Heller has
also published a book in which he
examines the role of memes meme isn't
internet for cool memes our internet
folklore in the same way that in
traditional contexts fairy tales or
songs are folklore in other words
they're the stories that the Internet
community passes on people have been
sharing videos of the trololo man since
2009 when a user uploaded footage of
this old Russian singer to YouTube the
clip went viral and inspired dozens of
parodies
the same happened more recently with a
clip for Pharrell Williams number one
hit happy it's inspired people around
the world to shoot their own videos and
show off their home cities
the song was all they needed aside from
a camera phone and a few people so it
was very accessible and democratic and
inspired a lot of people as it was easy
to copy memes can also be political
Russian President Vladimir Putin likes
to present himself as a macho man a real
gift for the online community political
topics move people and as such are
things that people like to modify and
pass on the only problem with political
memes is that often you can't precisely
control what political direction they'll
take their political contents can be
very easily misconstrued so they're
probably not something for targeted
political campaigns an American
policeman using pepper spray again
seated protestors on the Internet these
images become a symbol of police
brutality
whether critical or nonsensical above
all memes need to be entertaining and
entice people to join in we're Christian
Brandis memes are now a full-time job
but it takes a lot of work to distract
others from doing theirs